so we've been speaking about
psychedelics generally is there one you
find
from the scientific perspective or maybe
even philosophical perspective most
fascinating to study
therapeutically i'm most interested in
psilocybin and lsd and i think we need
to do a lot more with lsd
because it's mainly been psilocybin in
the modern era i've recently gotten a
grant from the hefty research institute
to do an lsd
study so i haven't started it yet but
i'm going through the paperwork and
everything and
therapeutic meaning there's some issue
and you're trying to treat that issue
right right in terms of just like what's
the most
fascinating you know understanding the
nature of these experiences if you
really want to like wrap your head
around what's going on when someone has
a completely altered sense of reality
and sense of self
there i think you're talking about the
the
the high dose either smoked vaporized or
intravenous injection which
all kind of um are they're very similar
pharmacologically
of dmt and 5-methoxy dmt
this is like when people this is what i
know if you're familiar with
terence mckinney he would talk a lot
about smoking dmt joe rogan
has has talked a lot about that people
will say that and there's a close
relative called five methoxy dmt
most people who know the terrain will
say that's
that's an order of magnitude or orders
of magnitude beyond
i mean anything one could get from even
a high dose of psilocybin or lsd
i think it's a question about whether
you know how therapeutic
i think there is a therapeutic potential
there but it's
probably not as sure of a bet because
one goes so far out
it's almost like they're not
contemplating their relationship and
their direction in life they are like
reality is ripping apart at the seams
and the very
nature of the of the self and of the
sense of reality
and the amazing thing about these
compounds and same to a lesser degree
with the
you know with oral cell cybin and lsd is
that
unlike some some other drugs that that
really throw you far out there
um you know anesthetics and even
even alcohol like it as reality starts
become different
at higher higher doses there's there's
this numbing
there's this sort of um there's this
ability
for the sense of being the center having
a conscious
experience that's memorable that is
maintained
throughout these classic psychedelic
experiences like one can go
as far so far out while still
being aware of the experience and
remembering the experience
interesting so being able to carry
something back
right
you